طيب يعني لو اردنا ان نصف موقع الصين الان
حاليا بالنسبه للولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وفي العلاقه بالحرب البارده اين هو اين
تضعه
اصيل الان بلا ادنى شك هو كبرى او كل هذا
يعود الى اواخر السبعينات القرن الماضي
عندما قام دان شوبينج بفتح الاقتصاد
الصيني مما قادم
الى هذا النمو الاقتصاديه الكبيره جدا عبر
العقود الماضيه مما سمح لصيني يمارس سيتي
ثقلها عسكريا ودبلوماسيا ايضا
موقفه دونغا حينها وهو لنحافظ على الهدوء
ونعز قواتنا والان حصل ووصلوا الى هذه
القوه الى الحد الذي تستطيع ان تقوم فيه
الصين اسهامات ايجابيه مثل مجال تحدثنا
عنه وتخفيض التوترات في الخليج العربي من
لجنه مصلحه الجميع هنالك مناطق اخرى خاصه
في شرق الهادئ حيث الولايات المتحده
والصين بالتحديد لديهما خلافات وهنالك
احتمال
لخروج التوترات عن الطاقه السيطره وهذا
يقلقنا جميعا ولكن حقيقه وصول الصين على
انها من القوى الكبرى في العالم وصولها
لهذه المرحله اتمنى ان تساهم بايجابيه
اكثر من السلبيه
كما نجحت الصين على الاقل حتى الان في
منطقه الخليج الخليج العربي وفي ما يتعلق
بايران والامل بانهاء الاحداث في اليمن هل
يمكن للصين ان يكون لها دور على صعيد
الصراع الفلسطيني الاسرائيلي ام ان هذا
الملف ملف امريكي بحث لا يمكن لاحد التدخل
به او او مساعده اي طرف على المضي قدما
نحو
خطوه ايجابيه
اعتقد بان الصينيين بكل حذار سيختارون
الحالات او الاوضاع التي تدخلون فيها ولن
يبذل جهود الدبلوماسيه لا يرون فيها املا
كبيرا بالنجاح ولا اعتقد بانهم يرون املا
كبيرا من النجاح اذا ما ارادوا التدخل
بشكل مباشر في النزاع الاسرائيلي
الفلسطيني فسوف يستنتجون كما استنتج
الكثيرون بين طرف الخارجي الاساسي ولا
الولايات المتحده نظرا للعلاقات القويه
جدا بين امريكا واسرائيل لذلك اشكوا بان
الصينيين سيحاولون التداخل في هذا النزاع